we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman hydrant is the delicious
fruit drink powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant.com pacman and
use the code pacman
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save
20 percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman it's great to
be back from the thanksgiving holiday
here in the united states
i didn't do much i will talk about it on
the bonus show
and the reason i didn't do much is with
vaccines
for coronavirus so close why would i do
anything
at this crucial time with light at the
end of the tunnel to make
the spread potentially even worse and
unfortunately
it looks like it's going to get really
really bad we
don't yet have the numbers that will
tell us the impact of the thanksgiving
travel reportedly almost as many people
as in a normal year a non-pandemic year
flying around for thanksgiving we won't
know the impact of that
in terms of cases for a couple of weeks
and in terms of deaths for a couple of
more weeks beyond that because of the
timeline of
these spike and super spreader events
but even without the numbers that will
be caused by thanksgiving travel and
gatherings
the united states coronavirus pandemic
is completely out of control and donald
trump insisted
in the run-up to the election that it
was all political
after the election you're not going to
hear anything else about the virus
november 4th
everything opens schools everything
everything everything opens
obviously this has not happened and the
opposite is actually the truth
in terms of cases per capita the united
states has risen to
sixth most cases per capita in the world
excluding a couple of really tiny
countries and territories places like
andorra which kind of throw off the data
similarly when it comes to deaths using
that same standard the united states has
the seventh
highest rate of deaths per capita
in the world these are horrifying
numbers now in terms of cases and deaths
in the u.s the u.s now has roughly
13.7 million known cases
and 273 000 known
deaths the numbers for both could be
30 or even 50 percent higher as we've
previously described remember
trump said 15 cases will soon be zero
nobody here has died
we might have 50 000 deaths maybe but
probably not
and on and on and on we are at 273
000 nothing is being done at this point
in time
now recall that we had a spike in april
to about 32 000 cases per day
and at the time it looked like a big
spike and then they dipped back down
and then we had a second spike in july
that doubled that up to about 70 000
cases per day
and it seemed crazy and they started to
decline but dr
fauci said if we are not careful we will
get beyond
100 000 cases per day in the fall
and half the country didn't believe dr
anthony fauci
and looking at the chart of those cases
those initial spikes now look like mere
mole hills compared
to the current numbers where we saw as
many as 178
000 cases in a single day a few days ago
now over the last few days because of
the holiday
combined with weekend uh reporting which
tends to be lower
we see a bit of a dip we expect to see
those numbers caught up on
in the next few days and of course it's
not just cases it's also
deaths death spiking we are back up to
the numbers of that
horrible early spike of about 2 000
deaths a day
we even had 2 300 deaths in a single day
last week and it is completely possible
and plausible that these numbers are
going to keep climbing
due to thanksgiving gatherings now
heading into christmas and new year's
there are people who are just determined
to live as if everything is completely
normal
large indoor gatherings it is going to
be insane
now as i mentioned earlier we are very
close to vaccines we are expecting at
this point it is
it is no longer a pipe dream we are
expecting
that there will be people being
vaccinated
on either december 11th or december 12th
december 8 to 10 the fda is meeting with
these
non-partisan advisory boards to say are
we doing an emergency use
authorization um at least for the pfizer
vaccine and then we'll see
if the moderna vaccine it would be
discussed at that same time or maybe
that one will take a little bit longer
if that is the case vaccines are already
being transported
united airlines flights bringing
vaccines from belgium
to chicago for further distribution the
logistics are on the move
we are this close we could have 20
million people vaccinated by the end of
december
we could have another 30 million by the
end of january
another 30 to 35 million by the end of
february so what that means is
that in the next three months it's
basically december by in the in december
january february
we could potentially have 80 to 85
million
people vaccinated by the last day of
february
we are getting close this is not the
time
to behave irresponsibly and see this
absolutely
almost cartoonish rise in cases dr fauci
saying to martha raddatz over the
weekend that you could see
this looks like a surge you could see
thanksgiving and christmas
accelerated even more to a surge upon a
surge
let's not do it this has nothing to
trump failed yes
trump failed trump's got days left in
his presidency
let's get this under control because we
are so so close
um and we'll keep you posted on the
numbers and the data but it is looking
very very ugly so far so this next story
this this segment i'm going to do right
now this is the prototypical segment
that i think is some of the best stuff
that we do
and it does terribly in terms of
audience
but it is so interesting and it is so
worth doing and so informative let's dig
right into it
i told you previously that joe biden
will
be selecting janet yellen as his
treasury secretary
and we talked about janet yellen's
politics and i pointed out there are
things
that should make progressives reasonably
happy about the selection of janet
yellen
there are things that might make
progressives not so
happy about janet yellen but the big
picture about janet yellen as treasury
secretary
is that anything that joe biden is able
to get done with the house and senate
that he ends up having
janet yellen is not likely to stand in
the way at all
meaning that she will not be the
impediment to joe biden getting his
campaign platform done
she's a relatively good selection she's
the first woman in that position
and she's a true economic uh
uh she's she's an academic she's an
academic from the field of economics
she is also beyond that
a really clever economist and i was
doing some
research on her and came across an
article that she published
along with george akerloff in the
quarterly journal of economics back in
may of 1990
this is 30 years ago now okay and she
published a paper
about the so-called fair wage effort
hypothesis
this is not just economics it's social
psychology and it's sociology
and it's brilliant and fascinating and
it just reinforces that joe biden is
picking serious people
donald trump's treasury secretary is
steven mnuchin
who was a hedge fund guy who lived in a
hotel and drove a porsche while he was
getting his undergraduate degree and
then went and worked you know in big
finance hedge funds etc
janet yellen is a phd in economics and
has published
scholarly articles and developed
original ideas of her own
and the idea that she has developed in
this fair wage effort hypothesis this is
again
30 years old but it's talking about the
rigor academic rigor that janet yellen
is capable of the idea is the following
if your wage that you were paid
falls short of your perception of what
would be a fair wage for that job
you start to not work as hard and you're
less productive
the idea of hiring someone else
wouldn't work unless you can find
someone who really doesn't
understand how their wage relates
to what would be a fair wage for the job
you've hired them for
and we've actually observed this
phenomenon you will
uh you often will end up seeing people
with different skill levels
doing the same job and getting paid the
same amount
and they end up with almost identical
productivity
would be strange intuitively right i
mean you've got two people
doing the same work one is significantly
more skilled in ways that are relevant
to that work
but because of this pressure that janet
yellen describes that exists where
you are comparing your wage to the fair
wage
even if you are more skilled and you
would be able to be significantly more
productive
you will produce down to the level you
believe is appropriate for the wage you
are being paid
very very interesting there are lots of
studies
in terms of people having a perception
of the fairness of the wage they're
being paid
one such study is lawler and ogara which
you can google if you're interested in
this
and they did some really simple but
well-controlled experiments
where they would pay a set amount per
task and when they paid
less for the same task given equally
qualified and skilled individuals when
you paid less
productivity went down now if you're
interested in this
we're linking actually to janet yellen's
article in the description
uh for the youtube video on this story
but it's really quite elegant because it
directly refutes a lot of really bad
right-wing talking points
about the minimum wage and wages in
general and i'll give you some examples
of this
there's this talking point from the
right where
it's sort of like a a reductio ad
absurdum where they say
listen if we want people to have more
money and paying them more is better
why stop at a fifteen dollar minimum
wage why not make it a hundred and fifty
dollars an hour
or a thousand dollars an hour just pay
people make everybody multi-millionaires
now intuitively intuitively we know that
that's idiotic
and one of the reasons it doesn't make
sense is that paying people 150
or a thousand dollars instead of just a
reasonable minimum wage
it would not be an equilibrium wage that
makes any sense
in terms of the cost of living nor
relative to other professions it doesn't
make any sense
but what janet yellen's uh hypothesis
adds here
is that paying somebody saying let well
let's set the minimum wage to 150 or a
thousand
it wouldn't be in line with a fair wage
if you survey people about what would be
a
fair wage for traditional minimum wage
work it's not going to be a hundred and
fifty dollars or a thousand dollars an
hour
it'll be much closer to the fifteen
dollars an hour that's
widely now being discussed i'll give you
another right-wing talking point that is
implicitly debunked by janet yellen's
hypothesis
if you increase the minimum wage you
force businesses to lay off employees
and it
increases unemployment well hold on a
second if janet yellen is right
and the the literature suggests she is
if you pay people less you're making
them less productive
which means you either need to pay them
to work longer hours
or you need to hire more of them to get
to the same level of productivity
that costs you more as the employer as
well
the other one you hear which is similar
is you raise the minimum wage
you raise the price of consumer goods
well
the same analysis applies if you lower
the wage
and you make employees less productive
as a result
you still need more employees or you
need employees working more hours to
produce your stuff
you'd theoretically still need to raise
the price
of the goods that you are selling so
it's quite elegant
very interesting stuff and again
read it it's only about 8 10 pages if
you don't include all of the the
charts and data at the end you could
read it in 10 15 minutes
but you will very quickly realize that
we are going in the direction of having
actual expert adults in positions of
power upcoming
and we will have our political
disagreements with them but we should
all be welcoming this after the fiasco
charade
that the trump administration has been
check out the article let me know your
thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pacman we'll take a quick break and
be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program is mostly
funded by
individual memberships one of which you
can get at
joinpacman.com coupon code fresh start
is available for those who want it the
pardons are starting in the latest sign
that no matter what donald trump says
publicly
he knows his days as president are
numbered and donald trump has pardoned
his former
national security adviser the convicted
michael flynn
now remember that michael flynn pleaded
guilty to lying to the fbi about contact
with russian officials
trump announcing the pardon of course
via twitter
just hours before thanksgiving saying
quote it is my great honor
to announce that general michael t flynn
has been granted a full pardon no
partial pardon for michael flynn a full
pardon
congratulations to general flynn and his
wonderful family
i know you will now have a truly
fantastic
thanksgiving remember that donald trump
has already commuted the sentence of his
former campaign aide roger stone
he's expected to pardon many more people
between now and january 20th and on the
table could be pardons for
paul manafort george papadopoulos
steve bannon has been charged but not
yet convicted
rudy giuliani is under federal
investigation for possibly breaking
lobbying laws there are many others now
on the one hand you would be absolutely
correct
to say these aren't just mere
presidential pardons
for crimes committed that have nothing
to do with the president himself
for better or worse uh uh these are
not traditional or standard pardons in
the sense that many of the people
that uh are potentially going to get
pardons and some who did get pardons
already
their crimes relate to donald trump's
own campaign or administration or they
relate to
telling lies to help donald trump
so you are completely right if your
reaction is this is not
you know pardoning someone who's been in
prison for 20 years
for something you think is unfair these
are pardons related to crimes committed
as part of donald trump's campaign
transition team or administration
you would be completely right now at the
same time i'm seeing people
talking about oh trump needs to suffer
the consequences for doing this
he can't be allowed to get away with
pardoning these people who in many cases
committed crimes that were meant to help
hide the possible wrongdoing of donald
trump
my advice is don't even bother i like i
hate to be saying this
but we've got seven weeks left in this
administration
there is no chance that donald trump
will have
any negative repercussions from making
these pardons
my recommendation is save your energy
and your focus
and your sanity and get to something
else
because it's disgusting for me to be
saying it because it's the reality in
the united states
but he's going to get away with these
pardons as corrupt as they may be
now there is also the story here of
donald trump's hypocrisy
remember when donald trump explained
firing michael flynn
he also did that via twitter where he
said back in 2017
i had to fire general flynn because he
lied
to the vice president and the fbi he has
pled guilty to those lies it is a shame
because his actions during the
transition were lawful
there was nothing to hide trump isn't
pardoning flynn at least apparently
because he wasn't really guilty trump
concedes that
flynn did the thing he was convicted of
trump simply thinks it should be lawful
he's pardoning flynn
for other reasons presuming
uh uh that he believes flynn kept him
out of trouble
to some degree now if you really want to
take a trip down the delusional recesses
of the internet
there were pro-trump forums that when
donald trump pardoned michael flynn on
wednesday
they immediately started posting trump
pardoned flynn
because flynn is the last puzzle piece
in overturning the election results to
get donald trump a second term
just unbelievable delusions taking place
and think now of the full michael flynn
story as we understand it
during the transition barack obama told
donald trump i would not hire
michael flynn he's a national security
risk trump says
i'm going to hire him anyway and makes
him national security adviser
flynn lies to the fbi was an
unregistered foreign agent
lied about his contacts with russia etc
trump fires him and concedes
flind flynn lied yeah he he did it he's
guilty
flynn then helps robert mueller in his
investigation which leads to robert
mueller recommending no jail time for
flynn
flynn then recants the testimony on
which the no jail time recommendation
was made and
in comes donald trump and pardons
michael flynn it
it would be almost unbelievable
as a screenplay for a movie about
washington dc corruption
but it's real i i mean is is flynn the
luckiest guy in the world or is there a
different way that we should be thinking
about it
absolutely unbelievable the the pardons
will be coming
and i am as uh uh curious as you
uh about who will be on that list so
we're starting to kind of
wrap up various partial recounts and
vote audits from around the country
one came in from wisconsin and it's
absolutely hilarious
in wisconsin the trump campaign paid
about three million dollars
for a partial recount now remember that
in wisconsin the margin of victory for
joe biden was about 20
000 votes and the outcome of the recount
was that joe biden gained 87 votes
in total from doing this partial recount
so statistically
it changes nothing biden was winning
before and biden is still winning
87 votes when the margin is 20 000
doesn't really do anything one way or
the other
but consider that donald trump's
campaign paid
three million dollars for this partial
recount
three million dollars to find 87 votes
for joe biden
that's 34 000 per vote
that the trump campaign paid uh
well actually it would be trump's
followers
who donated money for the recounts they
paid
34 000 per vote for joe biden
in the end now of course the trump
campaign and trump himself
already have an explanation as to why
the recounts aren't helping trump
and it becomes part of the conspiracy
theory it's almost evil genius if it
weren't so stupid and predictable
which is listen if you recount all of
the invalid votes
all of the illegal votes all of the
fraudulent votes
then of course you're going to get the
same results if they counted invalid
votes once
and then they recount them you're going
to get the same result which
now brings us to if they knew this
why did they pay for a recount and there
are two reasons number one is
optics and number two is they raised
money for recounts half of which was
used to pay off trump's campaign debt
remember
the fundraising emails that started
going out right after the election
saying
donate to stop the count or to start it
or to recount or to
file whatever the fine print was
50 of what you donate 50 cents on every
dollar
will go to paying off existing debt
that trump's campaign has so you raise 6
million
you pay 3 million for the wisconsin
partial recount
and you put 3 million towards your
campaign debt and meanwhile you insist
i'm fighting joe biden's cheating by
doing this it's like the perfect
final scam actually against donald trump
supporters
and this goes to something else that's
very important the right doesn't really
seem to understand what voter fraud
is or in other words right wingers seem
to think that
elections could be stolen with actual
voter fraud things like
people voting twice dead people voting
filling out fake absentee ballots and
sending them in that type of thing
so then they do a recount and the right
wingers are wondering wait a second how
it didn't change the results the problem
is that the real way you steal an
election
this isn't news to many of you i know
you don't steal an election with voter
fraud
you steal elections with election fraud
that means
gerrymandering in the first place that
at the congressional district level
removing mail sorting machines at the
post offices to slow down mail delivery
to try to get mail-in ballots to miss
the postmark date when you know that
it is overwhelmingly biden voters that
will vote by mail
rather than trump voters you steal an
election by organizing voter purges of
registered voters using algorithms that
would more likely hit
democratic voters than republican voters
you do it by
closing polling places in democratic
leaning areas and
sowing misinformation about where and
when
you're supposed to vote in those same
areas none of that stuff shows up in a
recount
now fortunately all of those methods
failed
to steal the election from joe biden but
think about the entire trajectory here
before the election it was trump's going
to win in a landslide you had these hot
take right-wing youtubers saying
trump could get 400 electoral votes
trump landslide inevitable all that
stuff
biden wins and so they say oh it was
stolen you have to count the votes in
some places
stop counting the votes in other places
remember that in the 96 hours after the
election you had protests going on
at the same time saying stop counting
votes and start counting votes
then they say well do a recount oh but
the recounts change nothing
because they recounted the illegal votes
so then let's file
lawsuits which they do but then when
the judges actually ask trump's lawyers
are you alleging voter fraud here
in court they say no we're not alleging
that because they know they don't
actually have evidence of that fraud
so now they are on to the recounts
themselves
are bogus instead we need audits of
each vote and we need state legislatures
to send republican electors
even if the state appears to have been
won by joe biden
that's where we are now that's how far
we've come in nearly the month since the
election
this will have some trajectory to
december 14th when the electors vote
and then they'll come up with something
new that will get us to january 20th
what it will be
i don't yet know but we'll continue
covering it on our instagram page
at david pakman show also follow me on
instagram
for very boring pictures of my
thanksgiving
i'm david.pakman on instagram the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay so let's get
into now an interview that is like
nothing i have ever seen in the united
states this is an interview in which
donald trump finally out of his bunker
of media isolation after losing to joe
biden has started doing media again
on thanksgiving he took some questions
from reporters which we will get to but
i'm starting here
with his interview yesterday morning on
fox news with maria bartoromo this
interview is indistinguishable from a
north korean
state media reporter maria bartaroma
went along with donald trump's obvious
lies with
the same credulity as those north korean
state media anchors when they used to
report
oh kim jong-il got a hole-in-one on all
18 holes
kim jong-un doesn't defecate right i
mean it's it's like that
what maria bartoromo does here trump
told endless lie after lie many of them
completely corrosive to our democracy
and she went along with every single one
and then just to add insult to injury
or maybe better said to add a cartoonish
element to this
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just like on another level
altogether from from
the standpoint of comedy so let's get
right into it because we do have so much
to get to
uh check this out combining here the sir
routine with this new massive dumps meme
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
uh saying congratulations political
people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps uh in michigan
and pennsylvania
it's it's just beyond parody massive
dumps cost him the election huge dumps
were happening all over the country
as the results were coming in what is
going on here
we are a laughingstock and in this in
this next clip donald trump pushes
completely baseless
voter fraud conspiracies and if you're
watching
uh pay special attention to the looks on
maria bartoromo's face she's acting
like when trump says maybe the fbi was
involved
she reacts as if wow the fbi is really
involved in this
this is total fraud and how the fbi and
department of justice i don't know maybe
they're involved
but how people are allowed to get away
from this stuff with this stuff is
unbelievable
this election was rigged this election
was a total fraud and it continues to be
as they hide and the problem we have we
go to judges and
people don't want to get involved what
trump means there
by we go to judges and they don't want
to get involved what he means is
judges look at our so-called evidence
and find it completely lacking in merit
that's actually what's going on
here is trump just straight up saying
the popular vote numbers are wrong
ballot boxes and they use covid as a
means
to stuff the ballot boxes joe biden
did not get 16 million more votes than
barack
hussein obama he didn't get it joe biden
did not get
14 million more votes than hillary
clinton and by the way
he didn't beat obama in the black
communities you go to some of these
communities where
obama is very very popular and he beats
him in some of these communities
but all throughout the rest of the
united states
in a black community he does he does
actually poorly he doesn't do very well
this one should not surprise any of us
remember that donald trump
still hasn't accepted the results of the
popular vote from 2016. that was an
election that
made trump president and so as we've
been saying for months
obviously trump was never going to
accept the 2020 popular vote results
and he's not and then maria bartoromo
goes
full propaganda actor she says listen
if you don't consider the electoral
votes of the contested swing states
you win mr president critical part of
this story mr president but
if you take out the contested swing
states
electoral votes uh you're back down to
president trump having 232 electoral
votes and joe biden having 227
that is if you strip out the six states
with the legal
challenges so is the thinking here that
because of the various
ballot issues that the supreme court
will rule that the vote is tainted and
that will mean that they have to take
votes away from biden and not certify
is that the thinking and secondly what's
your timing on this mr president
because we've got some notable election
dates here that i want to ask you
this reminds me of the old internet
viral phrase
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
she would be a bicycle the point is
that's not the situation
swing states are part of the country
swing states have not been shown
to have had fraudulent results the swing
states merely count
like any others you don't get to not
count them
because the results are inconvenient and
maria bartoromo
really outdoing herself here and
um trump then goes on completely
delusionally to talk about assertions of
hundreds of thousands of votes that are
just fraud and
anything to not admit he simply lost the
election
and quite decisively but we actually
have
thousands of votes met in some cases
hundreds of thousands of votes more than
we need
in every swing state that we're talking
about so then
here comes in maria bartiromo uh
on a bizarre rant and she says this is
all disgusting mr president
this is disgusting and we cannot allow
america's election to be corrupted we
cannot
so you believe you can prove that the
computers
can circumvent any controls that are in
place
and before we leave the subject of
durham not only is maria making no sense
why is she screaming the entire
interview it's really bizarre
and this finally starts to wind down and
maria bartoromo's
interview ends with trump saying it's
statistically impossible
what happened and maria barto-roma
responds
by saying it's all quite extraordinary
mr president
they say it's statistically impossible i
led the charge
we won state houses we won congress we
won the senate
and i lost they say it's statistically
impossible
for that to happen it's it's all quite
extraordinary mr president we want to
thank you so much for joining me today
and thank you for your work
yes all quite extraordinary telling
obvious lies
which is what not only what trump is
doing but what maria does
this is now right-wing virtue signaling
they decry so-called virtue signaling on
the left
to signal that you're part of what i
would call right
think meaning right has two meanings
correct and right wing
you have to keep telling lies that most
people now recognize as lies
and this is not only corrosive to
democracy
it's a global embarrassment and we're
going to deal with that embarrassment
piece on the friday show this week
it is a complete and total global shame
that is taking place here and
unfortunately this was not the only such
event over the holiday weekend we now
have to get to how it went down
when donald trump took questions from
reporters on thanksgiving day
for the first time since the election so
we're working backwards now now we're
back to thanksgiving thursday
and donald trump finally took questions
from reporters
sort of technically although he didn't
actually answer
a single question in a real way he did
attack a reporter and we're going to
look at that in a moment
trump didn't even hesitate to come out
and tell the lies that his flunkies and
tools and cronies and lawyers have been
telling for weeks about this election
now i know that some of these clips have
blue flashes and some audio glitches
they are not
our glitches the master video we got of
the event
for some reason contains some of these
glitches take a listen to this first
clip
and i'm serious if the media were honest
and a big tech were honest which it's
totally not
it's it's a terrible thing that whole
section 230 is a disgrace that they even
have it
but big tech is totally dishonest if the
media were honest and big tech was fair
this wouldn't even be a contest and i
would have won by
a tremendous amount a tremendous amount
and i did win by a tremendous amount but
it hasn't been reported yet
but people understand what's happened
they know what happened
now of course donald trump did not win
by any amount never mind a tremendous
one
but he continues to say it and then he
starts getting asked
really specific questions like will you
go to joe biden's inauguration and check
out how he handles it
of course it is tradition you know that
it's tradition
for previous presidents to go to the
next president's inauguration so will
you attend joe i don't want to say that
yet
but i mean i know the answer i i'll be
honest i know the answer but i just
don't want to say it yet
look a thing like this possibly has
never happened before but maybe
people just didn't catch it but we've
caught it but why are we here
we've got hundreds of thousands of us if
i made it
excuse me when they don't allow
a poll watcher which is a sacred person
in our country people don't know what a
poll watcher is
a poll watcher is it's considered sacred
in our country would they throw them out
of rooms but that's not true they didn't
do that
and when they put them in pens your
attorneys admitted
this is uh this is really stuff for
history books
will you go to the inauguration well
listen i won
we caught them the poll watchers were in
pens
and they've used the term corraled
before you know giving this idea that
poll watchers were corralled
along with wild hogs and steer eating
cereal and grain from a trough
trump then casually sang they gave biden
lots of votes that weren't really biden
votes
still not a shred i mean not an iota of
evidence for that claim
they gave biden a lot of votes that he
would never have gotten
this is not a candidate that could get a
80 80 million votes
this is just not a candidate this is not
a candidate that beat
barack hussein obama with the black
voter
okay this is not a candidate that beat
obama with the black voter
this is not a candidate that beat
hillary clinton to a pulp
it just doesn't work that way remember
that all of those claims
are spurious and without evidence and
every court has found that to be the
case so far
trump was then asked despite your claims
that it was rigged and stolen by joe
biden
if the electoral college votes for joe
biden
will you step down and concede and this
caused trump to blow a gasket
and attack the reporter this is just to
be clear if the electoral college votes
for joe biden will you concede
well if they do they made a mistake
because this election
was a fraud just so you understand this
election was a fraud
i mean they have biden beating obama on
obama's vote
in areas that mattered in terms of the
election
in swing states and yet he's losing to
obama all over the place
but he's beating obama in swing states
which are the states that mattered for
purposes of the election
so no i can't say that at all i think
it's a it's a possibility
they're trying to look between you
people don't answer don't talk to me
that way
you're just uh you're just a lightweight
don't talk to me that way don't talk to
i'm the president of the united states
don't ever talk to the president that
way
this is actually very interesting
because people who are respected
and are respectable they never in a
million years have to tell anybody
respect me saying respect me
is something you hear from people who
are difficult to respect
who aren't commanding respect through
their actions
and trump says respect me now another
sign of just this sort of
shrunken down uh intellectual
smurf that that is donald trump trump
then of course saying that listen
he doesn't believe the georgia elections
are going to be fairly done
and if this leads to republicans simply
not showing up in
in the georgia senate races that would
be great take a listen mr president
if you don't think that the presidential
election was legitimate and if you think
that it was stolen
what confidence do you expect voters in
georgia to have when they go to the
polls to vote for
say lefleur or purdue well i told them
today
i think you're dealing with a very
fraudulent system i think i'm very
worried about that
they are tremendous people kelly lefler
david perdue tremendous people they
should be in the united states senate
they're desperately needed
but i told them today i said listen you
have a fraudulent system
you have a system with the flick of a
switch or the putting in of a new chip
can change the course of history and
you have to be very careful and again
the funny thing about this is
there is actually a republican movement
to boycott
the runoff elections in georgia oh great
have at it that would help democrats
take the senate i encourage republicans
if they really do believe this system is
fraudulent then just don't participate
leave the voting
uh to those that will be voting for
rafael warnock and john ossoff i would i
would be glad to see that
trump also believes that pennsylvania
state senators are going to overturn the
election
and he falsely claims that he actually
won georgia very easily
in philadelphia you take a look we've
had excellent meetings with
senators from pennsylvania republican
senators and others
uh and they're seeing things they knew
it was dishonest but they didn't know it
was this dishonest no and you'll see it
all
you'll see it all so we'll see speaking
of george i'll be going there
i spoke with the two great senators
they're great senators kelly and david
i'll probably be going on saturday we're
looking for a site we're going to have a
tremendous turnout and we seem to always
have a good turnout
the people are very disappointed that uh
we were robbed
listen uh republicans in pennsylvania
are telling trump he won so he must have
won
and trump mentioning a rally in georgia
there he said saturday people thought it
meant this past saturday
i guess it's going to be this coming
saturday december
uh fifth i guess that is we will
certainly cover it live
if it happens and then just a final
moment of insanity trump claiming that
all of the election results in georgia
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania
were fraud in a completely deranged
outburst
our signatures the reason they don't
want to show our signatures is very
simple
because we will find thousands and
thousands a very close race it's hair
thin
but we'll find thousands and thousands
of discrepancies
fraud why they aren't wanting to show
those signatures
is amazing they're doing recounts and
even in the recount they found thousands
of votes that were
off but now we want to look at the
signatures and you will find tens of
thousands of false ballots
fraud forged ballots you'll see it
all over you're going to see a lot of it
and you go to pennsylvania you saw the
meeting we had yesterday with
pennsylvania
uh you saw people come up and they went
to vote and they said no
you can't vote somebody else already
sent in a ballot
and a woman but this is happening tens
of thousands of times
i think it was six hundred and some odd
thousand six hundred and eighty seven
thousand
uh fraudulent votes cast in pennsylvania
and i will tell you the uh if you look
at the state house now the republican
state house they're starting to see
what's going on there
but they've really known it for a long
time then you go to michigan
and you look at what happened in wayne
county in detroit i went through a list
so trump just goes on and on claiming
that he really won
everything there was a woman and there
was a guy
and some irregularities biden didn't
really win is the takeaway and this is
the deranged stuff that
you know you would hope would never
happen in the united states like as
toxic as american politics is
you wouldn't expect that it would get
this bad
except this time we did expect it and we
were right to
all of those republican hot takes saying
you guys are going overboard
trump's never going to do any of this
he's doing all of it he's never conceded
he's claiming he's won six or more
states that he lost
he won't commit to going to the
inauguration he won't stop
filing lawsuit after lawsuit to try to
steal it
our most catastrophic predictions all
came
true incredibly now the question is what
will he do
in the remaining time up until january
20th
what a time to be alive my friends the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded
by caltech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so in addition to chris wallace and neil
cavuto we've seen
fox news host eric shawn sort of start
to play the role of a so-called
truth-teller on fox news and i always
have to
issue caveats by truth teller on fox
news i
merely mean he acknowledges that donald
trump lost the election that
it's a very low standard and chris
wallace and neil cavuto have been
willing to say that
eric shawn also is willing to say joe
biden won
and on fox news this is sort of a
controversial truth to be
told when half the network still refuses
to say it and in a little bit we're
going to talk about how fox news has
radicalized its viewers to the point
that
they are now too radical for fox but
part of what's going on
is that some people are trying to
acknowledge basic truths on fox
and they're getting crushed and anchor
shep smith was one of those people on
fox but he left
now on cnbc and maybe eric shawn is the
guy taking shep's place to some degree
check this out uh eric sean
fact-checking some of donald trump's
obvious lies
that trump told on the same network
just hours earlier in his interview with
maria bartoromo the
complete brown-nosing trump sycophant
we played clips from the maria bartoromo
interview earlier here is eric shawn
starting to pick it apart
this election was a total fraud
and it continues to be as they hide and
the problem we have we go to judges and
people don't want to get involved
that is of course president trump
claiming massive voter fraud this
morning his words
they stuffed the ballot box it was a
quote fake election
all this despite the fact that his
campaign has failed to prove any of this
in court
in fact your government election
officials experts and others many of
them republican
including trump appointed officials say
that the president's claims are
false and unsubstantiated he does though
promised to reveal the alleged fraud in
court including a slew of affidavits
from people who say they did witness
election wrongdoing
but legal experts note affidavits are
not necessarily
fact i like this because in just 30
seconds
he puts the entire case up front to the
fox news audience he's making claims for
which there is no evidence
affidavits aren't necessarily fact and
we really have to keep talking about
that sworn affidavits
are a form of evidence that is sometimes
admissible
and sometimes not and it is up to a
judge and jury to determine whether it
is credible when a
when an eyewitness testifies in person
in a trial
because they testified that doesn't mean
you necessarily believe everything they
say
you may find their testimony credible or
not or not credible
or you might find it accurate but
irrelevant to the crux of what is being
discussed
much the same way these sworn affidavits
people could be lying
or not people could be telling the truth
as they
remember it and be wrong or they may be
telling the truth and be right
and those truths might not really mean
anything about whether joe biden
actually won
some of these states and affidavits are
just like anything else in terms of
evidence
then eric shawn hilariously wants to
talk about
these supposed massive dumps
that donald trump mentioned take a look
let's break down
to so of some of what the president
claimed this morning he says there were
massive dumps of
illegal votes in in biden's favor
specifically pointing out detroit here's
the president
you just take a look at just about every
state that we're talking about every
swing state
that we're talking about and they did
these massive dumps of votes
and all of a sudden i went from winning
by a lot
to losing by a little well officials say
these are not illegal dumps that's just
the
counting of the many mail and ballots
that are entered into the computer
system
are these illegal votes is that a proof
of
massive voter fraud well there's no
evidence to substantiate
that uh and when you talk to republicans
in these states or on these
election boards very few of them are uh
substantiating that at all the problem
here is that i don't know
if the average fox news viewer
understands the meaning of this language
because
when the axios reporter says there's no
evidence to substantiate that
what it means is it's a claim without
evidence whatsoever
there's an invisible purple elephant
right here next to me you just can't see
them because they're invisible
well there's no evidence to substantiate
that what that means is it's a claim
i've made
and there is no reason whatsoever to
believe it that's what it means
i don't know that that really works for
the fox news audience
rand paul actually is one of the people
who jumped on this massive dump story
he treated quote interesting trump
margin
of defeat in four states occurred
in four data dumps between 134 and 6 31
am
statistical anomaly anomaly
fraud look at the evidence and decide
for yourself
so what rand paul means is during a five
hour period on election night votes were
being counted
he's acting like at the 36 second
past 5 41 am mark
all the votes came in flipping eight
states from trump to biden it's like no
it was election night many states aren't
even allowed to count mail-in ballots
until polls close
thanks mostly to republicans and so
overnight
during a five-hour period votes came in
from various states and results were
updated to reflect that
they're making a controversy where none
exists let's look at a little more of
eric shawn's kind of pulling a part of
trump's lies
yeah they picked up seats in the house
uh the president says thousands of dead
people voted here's that
there are a lot of dead people that
so-called voted in this election
but dead people were in some cases
in many many cases thousands of cases
voted
officials point out that does happen
sometimes either clerical errors or
maybe a husband or wife votes in the
name of uh
of someone who's deceased that's a
felony was that enough to change this
election
statistically likely not when you just
look at the number of deaths that have
been out there
that you know and you transpose that
onto the universe of ballots
so another talking point debunked dead
people voting
and then finally here eric sean pointing
out what this is really all about
finally hans it seems that we have a
president who he can't wrap his
brain or mind around the fact he can't
process the fact that someone
who he thinks is so inferior to him uh
won the election maybe or maybe he's
just establishing a predicate for
running in 2024.
so you know i i like you know i don't
know what the president's
overall long-term strategic plan is here
if there's a plan or even if it's
strategic
but uh we know at least rhetorically
he's not accepting it
and he's clearly laying the predicate
for a run
in 2024. as eric sean points out
trump cannot wrap his mind around the
idea that he lost to someone
that he considered was very much
inferior to him
so two things here first of all the
takeaways the only takeaway you need
factually about the allegations
is there's no evidence for the things
that trump claims in public
in the court filings the things trump
claims they don't put in the court
filings because the lawyers know they're
not true
in terms of fox news what's going on
here
is that they have radicalized their
audience
to be too radical even for fox news and
that's what i want to talk about next
we did a segment last week before
thanksgiving might have been the week
before
um about how fox news has been so
effective at radicalizing their own
viewers
that fox news viewers are now turning on
fox
because fox isn't radical enough and the
context was election results as you saw
there are some fox anchors chris wallace
neil cavuto
eric shawn they acknowledged that joe
biden won the election
and you saw furious trump supporters
abandoned fox
along with trump himself promoting even
more radical and farcical news sources
oan
and newsmax and our friend molly jong
fast
wrote a piece about this in the daily
beast it's worth checking out
it's called fox news is no longer insane
enough
for fox viewers and she writes they
built a huge
outrage machine then some of them tried
to be real news people for five minutes
and now the outrage machine is outraged
at them
this is the irony i think the phrase
that applies is
if you fly too close to the sun you will
get burned or something like that
they created this they told their
audience you can't trust the media when
they say things that don't sound right
about right wingers and you've got to be
outraged when you were told those things
and now their viewers are seeing fox
sometimes report accurately
that joe biden won and so they're
furious with fox
and they don't trust fox and they're
looking for something else
they were chanting fox news sucks at
various protests
over the election results in the days
after the november 3rd election
and molly writes in this article quote
but the problem is that fox had built an
audience that had gotten more and more
radicalized with each passing
year by fox's content so by election
night
when fox anchor suddenly wanted to play
things straight
it created a phenomenon whereby fox news
was unable to keep up with the
conservative outrage
generated by fox news and this is
exactly right
and part of it is that you still have on
fox news itself people promoting and
supporting trump's voter fraud theories
this is part of the radicalization fox's
opinion people have radicalized their
viewers against anyone telling them
trump lost
it just so happens there are also people
on fox news telling them that trump lost
we looked at clips earlier from maria
bartiromo indistinguishable
from a north korean state media anchor
reporting news about kim jong-un
and at the same time we have eric shawn
saying oh well
biden won and there's no evidence of the
fraud trump claims exist
so this is where we start wondering
about the future of fox
you might see a fracturing of the agenda
setters in right-wing media where fox
news
sets the agenda maybe for what we'd call
more traditional reactionary ideas
and then the stuff of the last few weeks
the q anon stuff the types protesting
elections
they maybe fracture off to oan or
newsmax
it may all change after january 20th
when joe biden is elected
it all remains to be seen but the
important takeaway here
is fox itself is to blame for this at
least in part
they created a safe space for fact-free
baseless nonsense for years
which they attempted to present as news
this is the bed that they have made and
maybe they will suffer financially from
it i don't know
but it will be very interesting to see
what the right wing media landscape
looks in
for example six months a few months into
joe biden's presidency
once vaccines have been rolled out for
coronavirus
where will the conspiracies lie what
will fox look like
what will oan and newsmax look like we
can only wait and see
we have a voicemail number that number
is
david 2192davidp uh we're getting a lot
of
of calls like this people convinced
trump not only won but he will get four
more years take a listen
donald trump done one this election you
damn sorry boy
liberal there was fraud man it's so
obvious man
you demon rats lost there's gonna be
four more years of trump boy
mega yeah now for people thinking that
can't possibly be real that's clearly
you know someone from
massachusetts joking with you uh that's
a it's a caller we know
the uh number they call from is a
legitimate
west virginia number and we are seeing
these posts everywhere we're seeing them
on youtube we're seeing them on live
streams
people continuing to post maga2020
trump 2020. trump lost what on earth are
you talking
it's over i mean there's no the thing
we're moving on
joe biden is uh uh he's almost fully
staffed up
at this point in time these people are
going to be around for a while i believe
they will be with us
for some time we will talk on the bonus
show today about the supreme court
decision about limiting attendance at
houses of worship due to the virus
we will talk about vegans at higher risk
for bone
fractures producer pat will weigh in on
this explosive new veganism story
and we'll also talk about the plan to
reduce massive wildfires
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com i will see
you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost effective than expensive sugary
sports drinks
to get 25 off go to drink hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman if you're
trying to quit smoking or vaping check
out lucy which is a nicotine gum
developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save
twenty percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman